[Music]
hello and welcome back
to chess openings explained uh today i
am continuing the never ending series on
the nydorf opening
of course there is a lot to cover in the
nightdorf and we have
already gone through a massive chunk on
it uh
massive chunk of it tonight we are
looking to finish up all of the lines
after the move six bishop g5 uh in the
first lecture on the bishop g5 openings
we went through the mainline stuff
and that was the really theory heavy
stuff the
deep complicated lines where black could
get into trouble if he doesn't know what
he's doing
and so tonight it's going to be a little
bit of a nicer break from that
and i'm going to cover the rest of the
lines the sidelines that white can
choose after bishop g5
and then i also wanted to go through a
few example games
in the bishop g5 line and maybe even
some other lines if we get some time
because i feel like
all of this opening theory is great a
lot of the comments however have been
about
you know more of the positional aspects
what do you do after
you play all the opening theory and so i
wanted to highlight some of that as well
tonight
up first i want to look at this
variation that comes
after of course the night or opening
moves knight f3
takes takes knight f6 knight c3
a6 bishop g5 uh e6
and then believe it or not after f4
there are still
a couple of sidelines that white can
choose from we went through all the main
variations really after f4
but there are sort of these two tricky
sidelines that i want to
mention so number one of course i'm
recommending the delayed poison pawn
variation where you go h6
white goes bishop h4 and black goes
queen b6
targeting the b2 pawn
and so i did want to briefly mention
well what happens if white just captures
here first there are a few games in the
database where this happens
and the reason that white never really
wants to capture here first
is because if he does capture he wants
black to take back with the g
pawn sort of opening up the g file
making some weaknesses
on the king's side now of course in this
case
we can just recapture with the queen and
we very much should
and from here black is not going to have
any issues for example if white develops
normally with queen d2
you just go knight c6 the knight
on d4 is hits white probably isn't so
interested in taking on c6 and giving
whites
are giving black a pretty large center
to work with d5
e5 c5 is likely coming up so knight f3
is a bit more natural
and from here there is actually a pretty
interesting move for black
so if you guys at home want to give it a
shot
see if you can find black's interesting
idea in this position
go ahead in the chat room now and i
will give you a hint in a pretty
different
variation in the nightdorf this idea
does sort of crop
up as well so it's an idea you might
have seen before although the position
does look rather different
so what can you do here so yeah julian
in the chat asks will you be showing the
poison pawn variation and so i would
recommend you check out last week's
lecture
that was all about the variations that
come about where black captures on b2 or
the main variation where white plays a3
to stop the capture on b2 today
we are looking at the sidelines
so yeah aryan actually does have the
right answer here it's this interesting
idea
of g5 of course this showed up uh in
i think the the main variation of the
bishop g5 where white goes a3
and castles queen side and then pushes
on the king side
uh and of course the idea of this move
isn't so much
to like start ripping open the king side
it's more to give your knight this nice
e5 square and it really does achieve
that that goal
here in this position if white wants to
capture
this is in fact upon sacrifice by black
we can take take
uh knight takes but after b5
knight back to f3 for example bishop b7
queenside castles uh and king e7
now black is ready to develop this
bishop on this nice long open diagonal
this bishop is pressuring e4 and black
has plenty of compensation
for the for the pawn here
much more common rather than accepting
the sacrifice
is to just go g3 actually it's not much
more common
but it does make a bit more sense
looking
at my analysis and after g3 the
funny thing about this position is black
still manages to get
the e5 square which is why g5 is such a
good move in the initial position
of course in the other position we saw
it in white had already pushed the pawn
to g4 so this wasn't an option
but here this doesn't quite work because
black can take
take and actually just drop the knight
into e5 anyways
and this is perfectly fine now for black
if captures on e5 we can
simply number one give a check or number
two
just capture here f takes e5 is going to
be met with queen h4 check
and black has no issue regaining this
pawn
in the meanwhile the white king is a
little bit exposed and we're happy to go
in
for this end game where black has the
two bishops
just one other line for example if queen
e3 you can take on f3
queen h4 and after takes on g3 twice we
have a very similar position
where black again has the two bishops
can consider taking on c3
after white castles and a perfectly fine
position
not even down the pawn in this case so
just wanted to highlight
some options if white ever does end up
capturing on f6
after h6 i feel like even though it's
not the most common move it is worth
going over
because in your games i think uh
white is not totally unlikely to take on
f6 especially at lower levels of chess
you might say okay well h6 my opponent
knows
what he's doing after bishop h4 i guess
i'll just take on f6 to get a position
seems like a perfectly reasonable way to
be thinking over the board
and so if you face it that is uh those
are some ideas for you
after bishop h4 the main move of course
that i recommend is queen b6
going for the poison pond and poison
pawn and we went over the main stuff
with queen d2
and a3 but white does sort of have a
third option here
to play the move queen d3 of course i
went over some lines with bishop takes
f6
in these positions as well in the
previous lecture
but queen d3 is also an option the idea
is very very similar
to uh queen d2 but in fact i do think
this is just a worse version
for white you can capture on b1 as
normal
rook b1 is really the only move queen a3
f5 is the standard idea but now after
bishop e7
takes on e6 if you compare this with the
queen d2 variation
uh in the queen d2 variation you could
capture back on e6
with the pawn because you needed this
bishop back on c8 to defend e6
why is that well it's because white was
ready to jump the bishop out to c4
of course the massive downside to queen
d3 is that this bishop can no longer
access
c4 so you can actually go for a little
bit of a simpler version here with black
where instead of taking with the pawn
you can take with the bishop and while
you do give up the bishop for the knight
you get rid of one of white's most
active pieces in the center of the board
and black is doing perfectly fine after
96
f takes e6 e5 for example
d takes e5 takes on f6 takes on f6
takes on b7 and then a key move here is
f5 to block the queen out from accessing
some of these light squares
and getting a bit more safety for
example
it doesn't look so clear immediately but
play might continue with bishop e2
kingside castles this queen defends this
bishop from afar
queen g3 check king h8
rook c7 has been played in both
of the the games where this position has
been reached to add some defense for
this
knights and here after queen d6
queen g6 uh bishop h4 check
g3 queen takes c7 it turns out
that uh both of these games ended in a
draw
where white gives this perpetual check
but black can actually play on if he so
desires
queen takes h6 king g8 the bishop
now does get out to c4 rook f6 is the
way to play on
uh and the game could continue of course
if queen c4
white would be accepting the repetition
here now do you have to memorize all
this
i definitely don't think so all you need
to know is queen d3
allows you to take on e6 and then play
from here is rather natural right you
recapture
uh if e5 you take the pawn back takes on
f6
you want to take back with the pawn
might be a little bit unnatural bishop
takes
f6 is playable but then queen g6 is a
bit stronger
and then from here you play f5 to keep
the queen out and castle
and then these moves are a bit more
natural you bring the queen back into
play
you give the check so you can take the
rook and defend your guy
note if you take here immediately white
is nothing better than a perpetual
like it is really very much it's white
playing for a draw in this line
uh black has plenty of chances to play
other moves if he is okay with the draw
but to try to fight for more he does
have to find this rather accurate line
where you play rook f6 in the end and
get a small advantage
so uh obviously this is a bit of a
sideline you don't see queen d3 too
often and the thing to remember is that
it allows you to take with the bishop
because you don't have to worry about
bishop c4
all right with all that out of the way
that i
am saying concludes all of the
variations that i want to look at
after this move 7f4 so this is very much
the bulk
of the bishop g5 sicilian line
and now i'm going to take a look at
other seventh moves
for white and there are actually a
variety of them and i think
they're mostly all uh aimed at
preventing this exact poisoned pawn
variation
by black so let's jump into it let's see
what
whites can do in the bishop g5 lines
without f4
so here i have a game between uh andre
kovalev
and victor bulligan of course a very
strong player
and it's this example game that i want
to show first and foremost
to see what happens when white doesn't
actually play the move f4
so let's jump into it let's see we have
e4 c5
knight f3 d6 d4 takes takes
knight f6 knight c3 a6 bishop g5 e6
and then here there are no fewer than
seven moves that i want to take a look
at there is queen d3
queen d2 queen e2 bishop e2
bishop c4 bishop d3 and queen f3
and there are really two main ideas at
play here
all of the queen moves the queen to any
of these four squares
are aimed at being able to meet queen b6
with queen side castles that's
the advantage for white to move the
queen first
uh it avoids queen b6 lines because
queen side castles would be playable
as opposed to after f4 when after queen
b6 the b-pawn cannot really be
comfortably defended aside from the move
a3
in this game we see the move queen d3
i briefly want to mention most of the
ideas with moving the bishop
actually involve the idea of castling
king's side
and so then the game would take on a
slightly different tone and we will
see what happens there as well but first
and foremost
queen d3 played in this game
so what's going on after queen d3 uh
well the good news for black is that
because
white isn't playing this move f4
directly because he's also sort of
hindering his own development with this
bishop back on
f1 black's play on the queen side is
actually coming very very quickly
compared to white's play on the king's
side so now there's no real need to go
for
h6 trying to divert the bishop back to
h4
queen d3 also does a very good job of
playing against those tactics as well
there's also no reason to go queen b6
because queen side castles
is going to be the response but black is
happy
to either develop normally with knight
bd7 and bishop e7 which is perfectly
fine
or the move i'm going to recommend which
is the move b5 just immediately going
after the queen side
now with the poison pawn variation
prevented
white can go ahead and develop with the
move f4
and here uh natural development is sort
of the simplest for black with knight
beat d7
note that you're not really worried
about knight c6 because you haven't put
this bishop onto e7 yet
if you do play the move bishop e7 here
then you might be in a little
bit of trouble dealing with the move e5
and the threats of knight c6 at a later
date so
knight bd7 is a bit better keeping an
eye on this square not worried about
knight c6
because the bishop isn't here queenside
castles is of course the
idea for white but now black is very
very ready
to all uh to just launch his attack on
the queen's side uh he doesn't have to
waste any time at all in this variation
and he starts with the move b4 uh
here there are two options for
white really well i guess there's a few
options but the two main ones are
to sack the knight or to move the knight
out of the way
right both of those moves are actually
going to be playable
for white the good news for black is
they are both bad
um this line just isn't very good for
white and i think black has a very solid
advantage
if knight d5 you do just want to take
your free piece here
so takes takes and now the move knight
c5
is the move you need to find to sort of
uh coordinate your pieces together again
and gain time on the queen uh for
example if
rookie one check you can just play the
move king d7
bishop b7 is a playable move but king d7
is actually just better
so king d7 queen c4 for example and then
you just continue developing
and it's one of those night or positions
where i mean
you can memorize as much as you want but
at the end of the day it's
black with an extra piece and black is
just going to be
uh in a winning position if whites can't
find checkmate
which if you play well there is no
checkmate so
there you go uh i wouldn't really
recommend trying to study anywhere past
this
i don't think it's that likely that
you'll see this in your games
just know that in this case if white
sacrifices the knight
you're sort of winning the game and then
try and find the variations over the
board from there that's sort of my
recommendation
but in this game we did see knight c to
e2 because i do think knight d5 does
lose the game
uh and here bulligan just plays the move
queen a5 the point is
you unpin this knight without stepping
bishop e7 when of course knight c6 is a
major issue
and you pressure the queen side for
black and you're ready to play bishop b7
soon to follow here rather than
deal with this bishop any longer uh
victor bullock's opponent kovalev just
captures on f6
knight f6 is the natural follow-up and
now with this knight diverted from d7
white thought that he could push the
move e5 but black was just happy to play
the move knight d5
notably black is not so interested in
playing the move d
takes e5 because he's sort of opening
himself up to some pretty major tactics
on this d
file it's important in this case to keep
that file closed so you don't get
murdered
so knight d5 instead white brought the
king
to b1 defending against the threat to a2
and now with the file blocked again
black does actually want to take on e5
pretty much whenever you can take on e5
and not get destroyed you
normally want to it's a favorable trade
to open up this bishop
now natural development bishop b7 by
black
stops knight c6 and this knight came out
to g3
and now i want you guys to try and find
uh black's next move
in this game i will tell you that
black is sort of already significantly
better in this variation
because like i said it's just not very
good for white to play this way
with delaying f4 hampering his own
development
and running into b5 b4 so quickly black
does just get an advantage in this line
so
black's next move there are multiple
moves that'll keep the advantage but i
like the move
that bulligan shows in the game quite a
lot
so you guys are all suggesting perfectly
reasonable
ideas um
h5 i'm a little bit less sure about i'm
not sure we
actually want to be touching these pawns
on the king side just yet
it's not as if white is threatening to
play the move uh g4 himself
knight h5 doesn't really create too many
threats to our king
and yeah bishop c5 is is actually
running
into knight b3 a bit we don't really
want to give up this bishop for this
knight
like this so no one has actually
suggested
the the idea i mean rook c8 rook c8 is a
perfectly fine move
you can also bring the queen back into
the action you can challenge the d file
if you want
these are all perfectly reasonable moves
but the move that bulligan chose in the
game
is actually queenside castles and this
is an idea that i hadn't introduced
i think in any of my my lectures on this
type of position yet
uh we saw a game by mvl where he went
ahead in queensland castles
uh queenside castled but i did want to
make you guys aware
that these ideas do exist in the
position
if you ask the computer the computer
thinks the best move is like queen b6 or
rook d8
but queenside castle still maintains the
advantage for
for black and i did want to introduce
this idea because it does come in handy
very very often i think the reason
bulligon
shows it in this case is because these
knights are starting to eye some
annoying central squares
obviously there's still pressure on the
d file and white's idea has probably
become knight h5
that's why this move h5 suggested in the
chat was pretty interesting
but i don't know if it's quite right
bishop e2 for example
still increases the pressure and so with
pressure on the king side and pressure
on
uh in the center bulligon was happy to
just queen side castle
and the queen side does quite often uh
become a safe space for the
for the black king to live not too much
action going on there
by the white pieces so queenside castles
is a good idea
in the game bishop e2 was the
continuation just getting developed
and now bulligan does drop the queen
back to b6 rick hf1
and now you guys had found the idea
uh on previous turns i don't think it
was so good
in this position because bc3 bc3
it's a bit slow with knight p3 to follow
but after a few moves have been played
it does turn out
that knight c3 check is the tactic that
black was preparing
with the pin on the d file
working in his favor uh kovalev accepted
the sacrifice but after b
takes c3 knight b3 rook takes d3
or takes d3 obviously one side has more
queens than the other
and bulligan is going to go on to win
this game now the game continued bishop
b4
and this trade of puns white got some
activity on the seventh rank
but black's up a queen so what can you
do
at the end of the day it was
uh almost checkmate on the board for
victor bulligan
so yeah this example game i definitely
wanted to show
because it shows you one of those ideas
that i just
just hadn't really cropped up yet in my
lectures on the night or if queen side
castling for black
is often a great way to ensure that you
have a little bit of king safety
available to yourself backing up
let's go all the way back to move seven
so that line shows some uh idea of what
can happen after the move queen d3
black should just expand on the queen
side directly
go for this queen side attack and sort
of just
uh have a really fun game it's sort of
the ideal game that you're looking for
in the night or if you just
you get to attack white on the queen
side and the good news after queen d3
is that quite often you're just
significantly better right it's not even
bad
fantastic so queen d2
might look like an improvement on this
idea because you leave
this bishop open to develop but queen d2
is actually a bit of a mistake
because the move h6 is really really
powerful here
now of course i was just going on and on
and on about how
after these moves the point is white
wants to queen side castle after queen
v6 so the poison pawn variations
don't make as much sense uh and that
does actually maintain
uh that that does remain true here
the reason we're playing h6 here is
because we have an independent tactic
so if the natural move bishop h4 black
to move and win
what do you guys think does the chat
room see the tactic
great wolf asks if we're playing uh
like a king's indiana i assume he means
the king's indian
so why is it a consideration
white's pieces just aren't aren't well
coordinated
to attack on the queen's side i wouldn't
say it's a lot like
a king's indian because the structures
are just a bit too different
but white definitely isn't ever pushing
those pawns in front of his king
and uh the black pieces i think just do
a good job of providing defense it's
just very difficult to attack that king
on the queen side especially after moves
like king b8 the king does remain
safe if you remember we did see an mvl
game last lecture where he also castled
queenside
under slightly different circumstances
to be fair but
it was the same idea at heart so yeah
you guys did find the tactic here
it is knight takes e4 uh the same idea
with pushing the bishop to h4 remains
true here
uh the only difference this time is we
gain the tempo directly on the queen
and now for example if bishop d8 knight
d2
bishop back to h4 we can take on f1
and we do not lose any pieces and
maintain
our pawn advantage and it's a very
important pawn in the center that we
have won black is
much much much better so much better for
white is to take on f6
but this is going to turn into those
lines that we've seen before
where after f4 h6 white captured on f6
f4 is a useful move for white and more
often than not he's going to play it
very very soon so it should just turn
into those lines that we've already seen
so we've seen that queen d3 isn't great
because it interferes with white's
development
queen d2 isn't great because of this
tactic so
queen e2 might be another consideration
uh and here actually the line i'm going
to recommend
is to play this move h6 again and after
bishop h4
go bishop e7 because once again after
the natural move
queen side castles we do still have a
knight take c4 tactic
this move just keeps cropping up in all
of these variations
so what's better than queen d3
queen d2 queen e2 well it's the most
popular sideline
queen f3 and i the reason i say this one
for last is because it's important to
understand
why these three other moves aren't uh as
good
as queen f3 because queen f3 in my
opinion
actually looks like one of the most
unnatural choices out of these four
options the reason for that being white
really really does want to push this
f pawn forward and sort of try and
checkmate black
in this manner with f4 f5 coming after
the e6 pawn
so it's important to understand white
only really chooses queen f3
because these other three options are
are just bad
right if these other three options
didn't have these issues with them
then white would not want to play this
move queen f3
uh the reason queen f3 is better than
queen d3 by the way
is yes number one we're stopping uh this
side uh we're still allowing this bishop
to come out to c4
number two it's important for white to
stop this idea of b5 as we saw in the
queen
d3 variation uh so
here now white of course has the move e5
which does just win the game on the spot
so queen f3 preventing b5 and allowing
this bishop to develop naturally
the downside it prevents the move f4
for black for white rather
uh the play might continue with knight b
to d7
uh white can queen side castle
as is the plan and then just natural
development with the move queen c7
is perfectly fine and white's idea
does tend to be this move queen g3 at
some point or another
white should be looking to play the move
queen g3 to free up this f pawn and put
some pressure
on the black queen's king side this is
also the reason why i suggested the move
knight bd7
and not the move bishop b7 i like
leaving this bishop here to have a
little bit of extra defense for this g
pawn and now the idea i'm going to
recommend
is the move b5 white steps off this
diagonal so you are ready to push the
move b5 forward
and now there are sort of two different
paths that the position can take
path number one is a bit simpler a3 and
rook b8 to support the b pawn and
black's just going to push for b4
and the same type of queen side counter
play that we've seen a million times
before
for example if f3 defending this pawn
against
the oncoming threats or f4 even
i don't think it matters too much
black's idea is going to be the same
we get developed with bishop e7 stick
with f3
um the bishop is likely going to retreat
to e3
and here black is actually going to
king's side castle
rather than allow white to capture on g7
the reason we're so comfortable kingside
castling here
is because of this wasted time with the
f pawn
from here after a move like h4 for
example this seems like the most natural
way to create counter play
black is ready to push b4
and we are not so afraid of this h pawn
for example h6
g6 and once again i do think black is
actually the one
with an advantage in this position this
idea of h4h5h6 might be a little bit
crude by white
but it was tough for me to find uh
variations that that made more sense for
white
than just this raw idea of pushing the h
pawn forward
it's just too awkward for white to
attack on the queen on the king's side
with this queen blocking all of the
natural pawn pushes
uh and so that i believe
is going to conclude my analysis of
these various queen moves are there any
questions on the queen moves
and then we'll get into the various
bishop moves that white has
on move seven does everybody sort of see
how these four moves are all sort of
related
how black's play does vary kind of
slightly uh in the opening depending on
which one white chooses
but why white generally chooses queen f3
over the other ones
and what's wrong with those as well does
everybody sort of understand
if bishop h6 the 98 so yeah i do think
98 is the the better option there
if i can pull up the line oh and sorry i
missed a very important line
um
so for example uh bishop b3 castles
if bishop uh bishop h6 so yeah actually
not h5
does work you can just win this piece
and queen takes h5
uh still b4 to follow 98 is a perfectly
playable move as well i think black is
is still better
after 98 with the same idea but i should
mention before
i start recapping everything there's a
very important thing that you have to
know in this line
and that's that white is generally quite
happy to capture
on b5
is g takes f6 and move at any time so
yeah before we get into the sacrifice
let's take another look
um so here if bishop takes uh f6
you do just want to take with the bishop
i think there are some lines where you
can take with the g
pawn but i don't think it's ever really
wrong to take this back with the piece
unless you're playing like knight f6 and
losing your g
pawn bishop takes should generally be
played i think
uh but okay bishop takes b5 this is sort
of the
the big trick to this line and so great
wolf
has it correct it's a free bishop so
black should capture
and unlike most sacrifices in the night
or this one is not so scary
white's idea isn't so much to checkmate
black more so it's to get an end game
with three pawns for the piece where
black is just absolutely fine
for example knight d takes b5 queen b8
to keep an eye
on the d6 pawn knight takes d6 bishop
takes d6
and actually the best move here for
white is queen takes d6
when we do arrive at an end game for
example bishop f4
e5 bishop g3 knight h5
and black is going to capture this
bishop on the next turn
go ahead play king e7 likely want the
king in the center
rather than castling and bring the
pieces into the center
and like i said it's three pieces or
sorry three pawns for a piece
and black is absolutely fine in this
position not nothing really to worry
about here
if white does try to keep the queens on
it's still not so scary you have to move
knight h5 if you like you can also just
castle
um and yeah let's let's go with knight
h5
of course the queen has to keep in
contact with the rook so the queen comes
to d3
you can kick the bishop away come back
to f6
and even with queens on the board it is
just going to be
three pawns for the piece and this is
just just going to be a
rather complex end game to be fair but
one that black should have
no real difficulties in
[Music]
so now that is pretty much all the ideas
with these four queen moves so any other
questions here
now i believe the richter rouser is
something else entirely rami
but i am
definitely not an expert on the richter
browser so that's where my knowledge
ends
queen d2 in this position though
definitely not a great move
because of h6 and this tactic with
knight takes e4 that we looked at
okay well then let's take a look at the
bishop moves
so like i said this idea of bishop e2
very much changes the character of this
bishop g5 line after bishop e2
white is no longer saying he's queen
side castling and playing for checkmate
instead he's castling king's side and
trying to play a chess position which is
fair
uh bishop e7 is the way to go here we're
not worried about any funny lines where
we leave the bishop on f8
now because we know that pretty much
white is never castling queenside after
the move bishop e2 it's sort of just
not the right idea here for example
castles or queen d3 can both be played
either way
after king's side castles by black it
usually transposes like this
and from here i do think this is just a
kind of a worse uh position for white
than the normal bishop e2 variations
basically we still have this pawn on e6
rather than
on e5 and that's going to be the key
difference here
but black can still get all the same
play just with the added benefit
of still controlling this this d5
square and in the meanwhile white hasn't
really been able to take advantage of
the fact that this knight still stands
on on d4 so for example bishop f3 here
makes sense
uh knight f to d7 is a sensible move
stopping e5 takes takes
queen d2 and after something like bishop
b7
obviously the play can go on for some
time here
but black is totally fine
pressuring e4 as usual bringing a rook
to the c file playing for ideas of b4 at
a later date
uh all the normal najdorf stuff you can
even consider ideas of d5 as
as well i believe so that's pretty much
the idea of bishop e2
bishop d3 really isn't going to be any
different
again white should be looking to
kingside castle here
knight bd7 for example kingside castles
and play is
again going to be very very similar and
lastly if this move
bishop c4 you can just develop with
bishop e7
the idea now for white is to tuck this
bishop back on b3
it's going to look a little bit like
some sozan fisher-sozen attack variation
ideas
and i think the play is going to be
pretty similar here but black and just
castle
queen f3 for example and knight bdd7
this sacrifice doesn't quite work
because 95 unveils the bishop
and once again i think black is doing
just fine queen g3 is natural
knight c5 ruins any ideas of the
sacrifice
bishop h6 98 is pretty normal
and this i would refer you back to that
fischer susan lecture
for more ideas on position positions
like this
because i do think black is just fine
here i don't think black has too much of
an edge or anything
but uh it's sort of just changing the
character of the game to be the uh the
fisher-sews in attack and in fact
this may almost be a direct
transposition to the lines that we've
already covered
uh okay so that i believe
is it for these sidelines
in the bishop g5 night or so if you guys
have any questions for me on the bishop
g5 najdorf
now is your time if not i wanted to move
on to
some example games and some other
variations that we've pre
previously previously covered here
in the series
so yeah skull is the expert in the chat
on the richter rouser
thank goodness that he is here for that
no questions i love to see it
well then let's move on to another
example game
so this is going to be one between two
no-name grandmasters
that i had never heard of but i found
one clicking around at the database and
i wanted to show it to you guys because
i do think black played a very nice game
and a very instructive game for some
ideas
uh and the variation this is going to
crop up in is the bishop e3 english
attack
so for those of you watching live or
those of you uh watching
uh even in the youtube replay i want to
treat this as a little bit of a quiz for
you guys
those of you who have followed the
series from uh
from the beginning should already know
all the theory for this line so let's
see if you guys
can recall what to do and then come up
with some good ideas in the middle game
let's jump into it here white is someone
named andre
dragalov unfortunately i have not heard
of in black
is the enigmatic d bokorov
no idea what his first name is did not
check anyways
we have the night orf
that's what we're here for knight f6
knight c3
a6 and yes bishop e3 the english attack
so of course not gonna quiz you on this
one i'm sure you all remember
e5 is the variation i recommend and
after knight b3
chat room what should black be playing
after knight b3 what do we do what do we
do
scary english attack they're coming for
us
they are coming for us here
so yeah i recommend the move order with
bishop e7 first bishop e6 is of course a
fine move
but you do have to be aware that the
move f4
exists after bishop e6 because you are
committing to this bishop
uh coming to this square rather early
i like bishop e7 first bishop c4 isn't
really an
idea here but yeah they're both playable
i like bishop e7 first because it makes
f4 significantly less strong
while you have this bishop back on c8 so
bishop b7 that's my recommendation
okay of course white plays the move f3
preventing knight g4 if white played
queen d2 first
and preparing his english attack now of
course
is the time for your guys's other move
bishop e6 of course f3
sort of telegraphs that f4 isn't coming
so the bishop can come to e6
[Music]
why not bishop c4 it's just not really a
move here i think
bishop e6 is fine for black
it's sort of mixing ideas like you don't
really want to commit this bishop to e3
if you're going for this bishop c4 idea
and i think whenever white does want to
play this bishop c4 idea
after e5 it makes a lot of sense to drop
the knight back to f3
so you can challenge the light squares
from this manner as well with the knight
on b3 i think it's just sort of a bad
mixing of ideas for white so yeah bishop
e6 is going to eventually be the idea
and black should never be afraid of this
structure because you have very good
control
over d5 but okay anyways f3 played in
the game
uh bishop e6 uh queen d2
is the main stuff and what do we play
now what do we play now b5 looks good
yeah maybe b5 was playable immediately
but just as a general rule of thumb i
don't think bishop c4 makes sense there
for white because of the placement of
this knight
and white having already committed this
bishop as well
so yeah of course this is where we play
h5
this is the quote-unquote new line
where you stop white from playing the
classic english
attack where you push g4 push on the
king's side and try to murder you
and in this game white shows the
most popular move here against this move
order
by black and that is to shove the knight
on d5 immediately
so do we take this with the knight or
the bishop we can't let it stand
it's just too strong of a knight we have
to kill the knight
so how do we uh how do we do it did i
make this line
i did not make this line uh i say it's
the quote unquote new idea
uh maybe a better better better name
would be modern as skull
agar and the chat has said but uh
yeah it's just the most recent uh
innovation in this line i think
so yeah we do want to actually take with
the knight if you guys remember
after the queenside castles variations
we are saying
knight bd7 king b1 for example b5
and now again the most popular move is
knight d5
the difference here is that we do want
to take with the bishop because we are
ready to immediately play the move
knight b6 forcing the dark squared
bishop off the board to defend the d5
pawn
now in this position where white has not
queen side castled
we don't really want to go for the same
stuff because it just doesn't make as
much sense
we're not playing bit knight b6
immediately and white can play the move
c4 in order to defend this pawn so it
doesn't make sense here to take with the
bishop
we can still take with the knight and
should and that's what's played in the
game
and bishop f5 getting the bishop to an
active square
bishop e2 now and there are a variety of
moves available to black
but uh see if you guys can come up with
come up with some
for uh for black here yourselves
how many lessons have i done on the
night or too many too many
so you guys are definitely on the right
track here
so b5 i'm going to say is actually a bit
of a mistake and we'll take a look at
why
in a couple moves here see a knight d7
is actually the most popular move
there's also an idea to to give this
check if you want to be a little bit
tricky
just uh draw this pawn out to g3 and
coming back this is actually a playable
line as well
in the game though black improves the
queen to queen c7
which is also of course just a perfectly
fine move
uh and the idea is to contest the c pawn
rather early on and force white to make
a decision with it
in the game white brought the pawn out
to c4 and now black just castles
white castles and
another improving move by black is
bishop g6
rook a to c1 and yeah now i want to ask
you guys again
for your ideas of
how to continue with black because now
is sort of a critical moment
critical moment for black
why wouldn't you prevent c4 well let's
let's take a look here
let's take a look so yeah
this is why i was calling b5 a little
bit of a bit of a mistake
in these variations where white castle's
queen side he very often is looking to
provoke weaknesses on the queen side
looking to open up lines
on the queen side especially with our
bishops sort of drawn out to f5
or g6 and so because of that rather than
go for b5 and taking a ton of space
trying to prevent moves like c4
altogether allowing ideas like a4
it's better just to shove this pawn on
the b6 square
we want to keep things rather closed on
the queen's side when white is castling
king's side
and so this idea of b6
and we'll also see momentarily king h1
played in the game
knight d7 rook fe1 black inserted this
move h4 which is perfectly fine
bishop f1 the other key idea to keep
things closed
is of course this move a5 and so this is
what uh
black's queen side play sort of looks
like in an actual game i introduced some
lines where b6 and a5 made a direct
appearance
here though it's showing up not in the
opening but rather
pretty definitively in the middle game i
wanted to show you that this idea
does really persist uh even if you don't
see it
directly in the opening also note that
black wasn't developing this knight to
d7 now because in this case
i think it would be a pretty significant
mistake to allow the idea of knight a5
so black delayed developing this knight
until he had already played b6
to uh to prevent this idea way back here
knight d7 would be perfectly playable
but you would have to contend with this
idea
of of knight to a5 and i believe this
is the variation that we actually did go
over in the lecture and there we talked
about
uh bringing the queen uh over to b8 in
many cases in order to play this move
bishop d8
and kick this knight out but the good
news is we don't actually have to allow
it at all if you play like black does
here
there are some downsides to this as well
but just another interesting idea to
keep in mind keeping this idea of b6
open before developing this knight can
be very very useful
okay so king h1 knight d7 played in the
game
h4 grabbing more space on the king's
side also notably removing this pawn
from any threats
that this bishop could sort of uncover
and then a5 locking everything down
white plays this interesting move
knight a1 to give the b pawn some
freedom
and now again how to continue with black
where do we want to put our p
where do we want to put our pieces
hello brian so yeah that's a great idea
chess king
f5 is going to be one of the main ideas
here for black and it could just be
played immediately
uh in the actual game uh rather than
put the knight on f6 so yeah knight f6
uh to following f5
is sometimes a good idea but i don't
really like it here
and the reason is these pieces would be
stepping on each other's toes
your heart's in the right place trying
to get the knight to e4 though
but in the game bogorev actually chose
the c5 square for his knight which i
think makes a lot of sense
and the reason is it leaves this f6
square
open for the bishop which can be useful
in many many cases putting a lot of
pressure
on this diagonal so knight c5 was his
immediate choice
but it's all in combination with these
ideas of
of playing the move f5 so okay
knight c5 played uh white brings this
knight out to c2
trying to prepare to someday open things
up on the queen side
rook a to e8 was another great
preparatory move by
boca rev b3 was played and now we do see
the move f5
and this is black's main idea for for
counter play
step one lock down the queen side play
for white
step two push f5 and go after
the central play uh on the f and e files
uh now white was a little bit nervous
about this pawn on h4
potentially stepping in to h3 creating
weaknesses on this pawn and on the light
squares in general
so h3 was a dry golov's choice andre
and now we do see bishop f6 and it's
just great to see how coherent all of
black's pieces are here
this queen supports this knight on c5
also is ready to jump to the king's side
at a moment's notice
and supports this pawn chain from behind
the bishops are well placed for any
opening up of the pawns the rooks on the
perfect files to support the pawns
and this is exactly what you want to
look for straight out of the opening and
into the early middle game
you want all your pieces to be
cohesively working together
and in the meantime what is white's plan
difficult question to answer white is
now sort of
waiting for the the threats to come from
the black side of the board uh and
that's should generally be your aim
in these types of lines if captures on
c5 we would take back with the queen
yeah i believe so uh i i don't think
beasts
so bc5 is is also a very common way to
recapture
uh maybe it's actually even best here i
think really any way you take back
is is fine d takes c would be the least
natural to me giving white a past pawn
but bc and queen takes c are both
totally fine
i personally might take back with the
queen
although moves like queen e3 i might not
want to trade the queens
maybe i would take with the b pawn with
ideas of of uh
leaving this pawn in a5 or maybe pushing
it to a4
not too costly of a decision though on
the whole
rook to see rook c to d1 was played in
the game
and here uh black brings the queen over
to d7 i guess sort of
answering our questions about how to
recapture he brings the queen to this
square
which works uh well to put some pressure
on the light squares
for white knight a3 was white's idea to
get the knight into an active square
and now the breakthrough f4 does come by
black
from here we see bishop takes c5 and b
takes c5
tactically i don't believe you can
recapture this pawn just yet
for example queen a5 means you're gay
eights queen b5 means queen
d8 and i think this queen's like getting
trapped or something
uh tough to tell but probably
technically you can't do that i mean
definitely technically you can't do this
for example knight b1
bishop b8s here rook f7
queen's trapped i promise uh so
bishop d3 was played instead and then i
want you guys to try and find
black's next move after bishop d3
so yeah the problem with like a3b4 ideas
skullagar is that b3 pawn
is always going to be a little bit weak
and
i think black might even have some ideas
of uh
it's also just going to be very slow
right if you defend the b pawn first
and then play a3 and then play b4 it is
rather slow so you guys have the right
idea here
uh it is to push the pawn forward to e4
and this is a good sacrifice
to uh to keep in mind uh and this is
exactly what black was pretty much
playing for number one you want to open
up these lines for the bishops
and number two thanks to the weaknesses
black has provoked by pushing these
pawns so far forward
fro for white this is sort of the start
of an attack
on the light squares on white's queen
side and it works very very well for
black in this game
bishop e4 was played takes takes takes
takes and now of course the the key
follow-up is the move f3
and now we see everything coming
together with
all of the black pieces making a ton of
sense the knight on a3
making a bit less sense perhaps rook f1
was played in the game
bishop e5 and now again these ideas
still persist
and then it comes back to c2 and black
goes ahead and
goes ahead and captures on uh on g2
we see queen takes a trade of the rooks
and now
a4 as well to uh open up a file on the
queen side
now black is down a pawn but it's not
going to be a very useful pawn at
all for whites and as counter play
the white king is going to be very very
very weak and we'll see that that's
what ends up deciding this game in the
end uh queen f3 was played
takes takes queen a7 and now
black slowly invades with
the pieces
dodge is a perpetual
and more chess moves
like this is these end games are just
raw calculation
and trying to figure out if you can make
a threat to the king so i'm not going to
spend too much time here because this
has nothing to do with the opening
but anyways queen e3 was played and this
is a winning move now
for black with these threats of queen g1
knight d2 was played but now queen d3 is
check
well sorry black actually missed
checkmate in two here but we'll forgive
him
played queen d3 and took a free knight
instead and then
white resigned very very shortly uh so
i really liked this game in the night or
because it shows how even
if black chooses sort of a slightly
different
opening move order with slightly
different ideas it all comes around
the same basic ideas for black and black
also introduced
some really fun ideas that we hadn't
taken a look at before
like this e4 pawn sacrifice to bust open
the light squares on on the king's side
so key points i wanted to talk about
once again this idea of b6 and a5 to
shut down the queen
side knight c5 is a good square for the
knight because we might want to put this
bishop on f6 rather than the knight
then f5 is great and finally
this idea of e4 to crack open
white's light squares was all very very
fun
that being said we have a little bit
more time so i do want to move on
to uh one more game
we have one between players who are
slightly more famous
than the players in the last game this
one was played between
one magnus carlson
and alexander gr grishchuck
alexander groshuk with the black pieces
so
maybe you guys have heard of these
players of course still sort of no names
but we'll see their approach to the
night or here
magnus started the game with the move e4
of course we had c5 knight f3
and we arrive at the night orf uh
in this game magnus actually chose the
bishop e2 variation which was
the first lecture in the night or series
so if you can remember
all of this stuff kudos to you
of course the move that i recommend to
start with is still the move e5 the
typical night or
move of course e6 is playable but it's
not really the night or if idea
so e5 the knight comes back to b3
and once again which of these bishops do
we develop
yes great wolf has it you develop the
bishop to e7 first
not bishop e6 running into f4 ideas
so here as well it makes sense bishop e7
now after the move bishop e3 played in
the game
uh when we see white waste this tempo
with bishop e3
that's our green light to play bishop e6
because f4 is significantly less
powerful
with this bishop doing a little bit of a
stutter step rather than coming to f4
in one fell swoop
and then in this game magnus employs
this queen d3
idea so who remembers the lecture
on the bishop e2 with the queen d3
idea i wanted to i triple checked to
make sure i actually covered it
and yes i have a whole chapter on my
lead chest study
devoted to the queen d3 idea
grishik plays the night or if they all
play everything they can't help
themselves all they do is study opening
theory
that's all they do so what do we do
after queen d3
what to do
so first of all ask yourself what is
white trying to do
with the move queen to d3 why
why has this move been played
so of course to move things along here
white's idea with queen d3 is to drop
the knight into d5 he needed to defend
the e4 pawn before doing so and so queen
d3 defends e4
and introduces the idea of knight to d5
white still isn't looking to castle
queen side in these variations
uh not after playing moves like bishop
uh bishop e2
and bishop e3 and knight back to b3 like
all that like
it just doesn't make sense in this
variation
so knight d5 is the idea uh with that in
mind
what do we want to do well it does turn
out that knight c6 is a playable
variation this isn't at all what i
recommended
i guess the idea is after knight d5 you
would win a pawn
thanks to knight b4 which is very very
clever looks like white can just play
the move a3 though
the move i recommended is knight b to d7
i think first yeah and then after knight
d5 black
can simply castle and the point here is
that we aren't
so afraid of the move knight takes c7
the reason being
ideas of bishop g5 are all coming a
little bit too slow right there's no
immediate threat
to our our d5 square
in these variations because this knight
is not well placed to take advantage of
it
and this bishop isn't coming here either
so not afraid of 97 at all that
definitely gives black the advantage so
we can just castle
white then shows to castle and now the
time
has actually come to take this knight
off the board
we don't necessarily have to but why not
let's let's kill the knight
and so do we take with the knight or
with the bishop
what do we do what's to do
of course we take with the bishop if we
take with the knight here
um it looks at first glance like we're
losing a piece
turns out we don't but we do sort of
have to sacrifice this pawn
to give this bishop a square not fun why
why bother with all that just take
with the bishop now after e takes d5
this is all played in the game by the
way
uh grisham chose the move rook to c8
now i think the move that i recommended
was 98 but
as we'll see in the last game all of
black's ideas are very much related to
each other here
and so even though black shows the move
rook c8 we'll see 98 is still a key part
of his variation here
rook c8 just challenges the c pawn a
little bit and so white's happy to bring
it out to c4
now of course 98 is still the main idea
for black
and after queen to d2 once again i'm
gonna ask you guys to find
black's idea here black to move
see a great wolf has has great ideas
great wolf says f5 exclamation point
any ideas other than f5 though
anything besides f5
yeah apon has the idea i'm looking for
so does danilo
b6 is the most conservative approach
than f5 i'll give you
but it's the the principled approach we
love attacking
we love attacking white on the queen
side on the king side rather
and you can actually just play f5
immediately it's not bad at all
and this is more along the lines of what
i recommended in my lecture it's just
going f5
directly after 98 and it's perfectly
fine to play like this it's more common
to play like this in fact
but grishok first stops the play on the
queen side
which i think is is also a really really
great idea here
for black so b6 was the move in the game
locking the c5 square locking the a5
square
and after securing the queen side black
moves on to play
on the king's side rook a c1 was played
and grishik immediately plays
plays the move a5
now knight a1 and once again f5 is a
very natural idea
but in this game grishik actually chose
another interesting idea of g6 and
that's why i wanted to highlight this
game because once again
it's another idea that didn't really
crop up in the opening
lines that i was recommending because it
was just not really an opening
idea it's sort of a middle game idea but
i think it's an important one to know
so g6 is the interesting move
tried by alexander grishik
here white tries the move b4 to
bust open the queen side remember i saw
somebody in the chat room suggest the
move b5 here
we're not interested in opening the
queen side in these variations where
white castles king's side
white is looking for play over here we
want to lock things down
um so after b4 what should we do
how to respond to b4 what do you think
ah and so nicodemus has apparently yeah
he he didn't mention this idea
so
what to do
so yeah rami actually has the right idea
here we don't necessarily want to play
the move a4 that's sort of giving
white a bit too much freedom with this b
pawn to help support c5 at a later date
uh but we don't necessarily want to take
on b4 either
uh this white knight might just come in
and murder us
on on the uh on the c6 square if we're
not careful
so you do have to be a little bit
cautious here uh the best
option is in fact just to ignore this
move you don't
necessarily want to give up your option
of ever taking on the b4
on b4 but you don't necessarily want to
do it right away
right you're sort of showing your hand
so knight g7
continuing with the game plan is the
correct way to go here
magnus carlsen tries to move b takes a5
and black recaptures so white has
succeeded in opening up the
the b file the issue is he hasn't solved
this problem
of the c pawn so it's not going to be so
easy for him
to really make use of this b file and
get active play
while not leaving this the c pawn sort
of in the dust
and after bishop d3 we'll see also that
while black
has allowed white to open a file he
hasn't given up his control of the dark
squares and he plants this knight onto
c5
which is of course a very good square
for the knight
white isn't really interested in giving
up uh in giving up this bishop just yet
so bishop c2 was played in the game and
now a4
is the very rude move by uh alexander
grishik saying
nice night buddy good job good night on
a1 there uh whatcha gonna do with them
magnus brings his rook over to b1 trying
to make use of the
open file and now i do want you to try
to find black's next
idea as well like i said
grishok taking a slightly different
approach to that e5 move that we were
talking about
in the last game that i showed so
something other than this this f5 idea
so nico asks should we consider bishop
g5 when the white queen moves away from
the c1 h6 diagonal
i forgot to mention i think in the line
that i recommended in
this variation uh black does end up
playing bishop g5 straight away
i'll go back to that a little bit later
but uh yeah bishop g5 to trade the dark
squared bishops is always going to be a
good idea here for
for black
so yeah it's not necessarily putting the
pawn on f5 but we are
very interested in putting our knight on
f5 however of course if we do this
immediately
then bishop f5 might be a good option
for white
it's not like white is winning here but
we don't necessarily want to let white
get rid of this bishop in this manner so
to prepare knight to f5 grishak actually
plays
the killer move pawn to e4
and it just so happens that like this
isn't the greatest move of all time
in this particular position but it's
it's not like black is
is significantly worse either uh black
was just slightly better
and now i do think it is about equal
after e4
uh so of course the idea is you stunt
this bishop
and are ready to bring the knight to f5
uh just for reference the computer liked
the move f5 a bit more with the same
game plan that i recommended in my main
variation but
e4 played instead bishop takes c5 now
rook c5
and now white had his choice of pawns to
capture
this being upon sacrifice after e4
he chose the pawn on a4
of course though black regains the spawn
immediately with rook takes c4
and what has black gained well he still
has this f5 square for his knight
and he's gotten rid of the dark squared
bishop from white
the game continued with bishop c6 and
the knight coming out to f5 as planned
queen e2 rook c3 white does get to
capture this e4 pawn after all
but after rook a3 black has no issues
really regaining his material in the
long run
the bishop comes to an active square and
all of white's pieces make sense
the queen and the rook are ready to come
into the action as well
knight b3 queen e7 was played
takes takes hits this bishop knight d2
rook a2 and even material
and then a little bit later on in the
game we'll see that white got into a
little bit of trouble
with this light squared bishop and
black went upon and did in fact manage
to go on
to win this game uh did alexander
grishik against the world champion
so the ideas i wanted to highlight in
this game were in fact this idea of
e4 and this idea of g6 knight g7 and how
they all work together
to put the pieces on squares that makes
sense it's not
like the night or is this complex
opening where you know
uh what's the famous chess quote two
plus two doesn't equal four and you're
in a forest and there's like
a path out uh wide enough for one it's
not like that all the time
sometimes you just find squares for your
pieces
and that's exactly what happened in
these two games
as promised let me back up really quick
to just show
i think the line that's uh i was
recommending
actually i don't know if i'm going to be
able to find it i think 98
uh a4 for example and yeah bishop g5
uh so this is always going to be an idea
on the cards for uh for black just to
get rid of the
the dark squared bishops before they
ever become a problem so definitely be
on the lookout for that idea
as well
so there's a question in the chat how do
you play the night or if your opponent
doesn't know the main line theory
well you're looking at it you put your
pieces on squares that's what we're
talking about here today
these middle game ideas sort of persist
no matter
what move orders and what specific
choices
your opponent took to to get there and
yeah onos has the real quote you have to
take your opponent into a deep dark
forest where two plus two equals five
and the path out is wide enough uh only
wide enough for one
now it doesn't have to be like that all
the time sometimes in chess
you put your pieces on good squares and
you have a good chest position
that's that's what i like doing at least
that is going to do it for us here today
on this episode of chess openings
explained
that also concludes our coverage of the
bishop g5 najdorf
i've realized i never covered the 6h3
najdorf so i guess that's what we're
doing next week and then maybe we'll
have
uh even one more lecture on all of the
sidelines maybe i'll just mash it into
one mega lecture
and we'll we'll be done with the darn
thing but uh hopefully you guys are
still enjoying
this series on the night off i'm having
a lot of fun putting some work into it
every week
and i feel like i don't know about you
guys following along but i feel like
my skills in the nydorf have improved so
so much thanks to this series i started
knowing nothing and i feel feel like i
could have a conversation about opening
theory in the night or if now which is
not a place i thought i would be at
uh two months ago so anyways as always
thank you guys so much for watching if
you're watching live
be sure to check out the twitch channel
the fun continues with tactics time over
there if you're watching the youtube
video
that's it for tonight as always my name
is caleb denby
thank you so much for watching and i
will see you next time
[Applause]
[Music]
you